Hello,
and welcome back to the Rawkode Academy.
Today, we're gonna take on a fun challenge.
Now,
this may sound quite scary,
but at some point in your Kubernetes journey,
someone is gonna ask you
to expose one of their services to the
Internet. Okay.
So it's not that scary.
However, exposing services to the Internet does come
with a bunch of questions and
challenges.
The first thing you need to work out
is how are you gonna route traffic to
your cluster.
Now this really depends on whether you're running
on your own data center with bare metal
or whether you're using a cloud provider.
With the former, you probably need some sort
of BGP advertisement that gets traffic from the
wild Internet
to one or more of your clusters.
If you are on a cloud provider, you've
got another decision to make.
That is, do we go with one load
balancer
or many? One load balancer is cheaper.
However, you may not have the scale
or resiliency
that you need,
so you may decide to go with many.
Then you've got the challenge of which type
of cloud load balancer do you go with.
A network load balancer, an application load balancer,
or an elastic load balancer.
Then, of course, traffic is at our cluster
to be routed directly to the services.
Well, you could, but what about authentication?
Does every service have to build that themselves?
What about security concerns?
Rate limiting, filtering,
OAuth,
JWTs?
The list goes on.
Getting traffic to your cluster is just the
first part of the battle.
Making it secure and resilient after that is
the second part. You need good audit logs.
You do need authentication.
You need authorization,
and you need protections for malicious actors.
So what if this could all just be
simpler?
What if there was a service that could
handle all of this for me, including the
trade offs, giving me a simple API
that allows me just to ship things to
my cluster and keep my customers happy
without losing
resiliency, redundancy,
scale,
and hopefully not costing me the world.
Enter
ngrok.
Alright. Let's get our hands on the keyboard
and take a look.
Here we have some instructions that have been
put together
that allow us to deploy some sample workloads
and the ngrok
materials that we need to demonstrate its true
power within a Kubernetes context.
Now the first command here is to deploy
a sample workload to our Kubernetes cluster.
We can take a look at this
by popping over to GitHub.
Now we can see here that we have
a deployment,
a service, another deployment, another service, another deployment,
and finally, another service. Three deployments and three
services.
Now that I've reviewed this,
I'm quite happy to apply it to my
cluster.
And there we go.
All three services and all three deployments deployed.
We can pop open to the terminal
and run GetPods.
Images are pulled and things look good.
Now we need to deploy the ngrok Kubernetes
operator.
But before we do that, we are gonna
deploy the gateway I classes to this cluster.
We're not gonna go old hat and deploy
ingress controllers. Heck no. We're going all in
on the gateway API.
So let's throw this onto our cluster.
Sweet.
Next up, we need to add the helm
chart for the ngrok operator.
This is just available at charts.ngrok.com.
It really couldn't be simpler.
After we do our repository update, we can
then deploy
a Kubernetes operator with a helm install.
This just takes a namespace
and two API keys from the ngrok service.
Now as I like to leave no stone
unturned,
let's pop back open to our browser where
we have the ngrok dashboard.
I have nothing configured or set up at
the moment.
Now the prerequisites here are you need a
domain.
Now you could bring your own or you
can pop over here and ask ngrok to
give you one.
Here, I'll ask for Rawkode.ngrok.dev.
Sorted.
Now we need to get those API keys.
Let's pop over to, you guessed it, API
keys.
We click on create
and we say add.
This gives us an API
token,
which I'm now flashing to the world.
Let's drop that in here.
And lastly, we need the auth token, which
is available near the top by Get Started.
And I'm gonna click copy,
but not Flash. So
let's head back
to Versus Code.
From here, I can add a namespace to
deploy the ngrok operator,
in which case I'll call mines ngrok.
We don't need to create this first because
we are using the helm flag create
namespace.
On this, we can hit
go.
I'm going to paste in my auth token,
but I am gonna omit it from the
video. So let's see some movie magic.
Voila.
Just like that, all deployed.
Let's quickly recap where we are. Firstly,
let's run
API resources
and filter
for gateway.
Here we have a standard Kubernetes cluster deployed
with the gateway API
resources.
This is a new way of doing ingress
and you'll see how it works as we
progress through this tutorial.
We can also run get namespaces where we
have an ngrok namespace.
Inside this ngrok namespace,
we have the ngrok
operator.
We also deployed
some sample workloads
to the default namespace.
So let's hook up ngrok
to these services and make them available
to your friends, your family, your customers, your
colleagues.
Okay. So from the terminal, let's run curl
get request against our endpoint,
which is Rawkode.ngrok.dev.
Now from this, we can see that we
hit the ngrok network.
We see cdn.ngrok.com
and a whole bunch of other stuff.
So let's run this again with a dash
v so we can see the response
and type in our domain name again.
Up here we see 404 not found.
So let's pop over to the ngrok platform
and just hit refresh. You'll see that under
endpoints
we have our domain name.
The problem is we haven't given it anywhere
to route that traffic.
And as you'll see under edges,
it's currently blank,
so let's fill in some of those blanks.
We head over to Versus Code, here I
have the missing pieces that we need to
apply to our cluster.
Now don't worry, this code will all be
available. The link will be in the show
notes when you're ready to try it out.
The first thing we need to do is
create a gateway class
that says s gateway will be powered by
the ngrok gateway controller,
which we already deployed with the help char.
Next, we set up a gateway
to be configured with our hostname Rawkode.ngrok.dev.
This gateway then needs to know how to
route traffic.
So here we have an HTTP route,
which then matches based on path and directs
to each of the three services we deployed
earlier: build,
test and deployment.
Given that, we can then just hit go
and deploy this to our cluster.
We'll now see that the three resources were
created.
So let's head back to our terminal
where we can run kubectl
get
gateway,
gateway class,
and HTTP
routes.
We'll see that this is now all provisioning,
And if we head over
and refresh our edges, we'll see that we
now have an edge for our host name.
Now that is exciting.
So now I'm curious. What happens if we
curl
Rawkode.ngrok.dev?
Well, we still get a four zero four.
So let's try that again. However, let's do
h t t p s Rawkode
dot ngrok dot dev
slash builds.
And now we're getting an empty array.
Does that mean we're hitting our service? Well,
let's add v
for verbose.
Rawkode.ngrok.devbuilds.
Now we can see that we're getting an
HTTP
200.
Okay. But that's just one service,
so let's pop back over to Versus Code
where I have this very sophisticated
script
that will curl each of the endpoints that
we have the path prefix routing configured for
and print out the status code.
Here we see 202200.
Everything is working great.
But we're not just here to show you
that ngrok can make our ingress to our
cluster simpler.
Although it already has,
we haven't configured a cloud load balancer, but
our cluster is on the cloud.
So what else can ngrok bring to the
table?
Let's take a look at one example,
rate limiting. So we're gonna apply one more
resource to our cluster. This time it is
an ngrok traffic policy.
I'm gonna call it rate limiting because we're
going to enforce some rate limiting.
And what we're saying here is just that
we have an inbound policy with a name,
with an expression,
where we're just looking for the request method
to be a POST or a POST. Essentially,
we're targeting the rights to our system and
we probably don't want anyone to apply too
many rights too quickly and overload our database.
Slightly contrived,
but it proves a point.
We then apply an action
which is
if we receive
more than 10 requests over a slide in
sixty second window from a single IP address
we want to start rejecting those. This is
identifying a potential malicious actor writing too much
to our system,
potentially trying to perform some sort of denial
of service attack.
I then have a curl command down here
which will execute 38 requests almost instantaneously
and we'll see how those fare.
But there's one thing we need to do
first. There's two things we need to do.
We need to apply this to our cluster.
We
then need to attach that to one of
our roots. This rate limit does not apply
to every single service. We need to add
the filter to our HTTP root object.
Before this I'm going to do a kubectl
edit HTTP
roots.
This will pop open all of the roots
in our cluster where I can pop down
to the matches on builds. Why?
Because the curl request that I'm going to
execute is going to try and hit builds
trigger.
Now we just need to make sure this
lines up correctly
which should be this rule here
back end matches filters.
Perfect.
We can save this and close
where it has now been edited and applied
to our cluster.
If we head back over to Versus Code,
we now see our simple script to execute
30 cURL requests.
So let's
run our script.
And because of the sliding window we did
manage to sneak in more than 10 but
not much before the four two nines did
start to return.
Let's just run that again.
Four two nine four two nine.
So the rate limiting is kicking in and
working.
Awesome.
Now I think it's also nice to point
out that while we're using Kubernetes approach here,
which means we can do this as infrastructure
as code or at least, you know, yaml.
If we head over to the ngrok where
we were looking at the edges earlier,
we can change to our build
where we click on traffic policy. We can
actually visualize the policy here.
Now you'll see there's a lot here. We
can add circuit breakers, compression, IP restrictions, OAuth,
OIDC,
and so much more. The ngrok platform and
what I'm showing you today is just a
fraction of what it is capable of.
So go forth,
have fun, and simplify your networking life with
Kubernetes by adopting ngrok,
installing the operator, and taking advantage of the
bleeding edge gateway API
and build your API gateways today.
Have fun.